i've also had physical violence the
building we're in here margaret thatcher
house in fact was arsoned some years ago
my car was smashed up someone tried to
burst their way into my house at the
crack of dawn
every mp seems to have a story of
increasing abuse and a largely poor
police response
very mixed very mixed
not always
uh have they responded in the way that i
would have expected
some of the things i've had to face
certainly in recent years i have
notified the police and
not often got a pretty good response to
be honest
uh more interested in the process of
filing the complaint and getting a
statement from me than they are of
actually taking immediate action against
the people responsible is there a
problem yeah i think it's a problem
two years ago paula sheriff spoke out
about the relentless abuse she was
receiving
joe cox had been her constituency
here neighbor speaker under the shield
of our departed friend with many of us
in this place subject to death threats
and abuse every single day when she
reported it to the police they were
occasionally superb but mostly
ambivalent
when somebody was leaving swastikas at
my office door the police took several
weeks to actually view the cctv that we
had managed to obtain to establish if we
could see who was actually doing it and
then they wrote to me to tell me that
the man who had been doing it was having
trouble sleeping
when we received a death threat at my
office by telephone it was somebody who
had left a message on the the answer
phone the police came to my office and
they laughed
and then when a man was continually
harassing me over a period of of months
on an incessant basis the police went
out to see him and told him that they
sympathized with him
west yorkshire police say they're
looking into these serious allegations
but it seems that more security at
constituency surgeries is now inevitable
there are other options that are being
considered such as when you hold your
surgeries could you have offices or some
kind of protection while you're holding
your surgery now it's not for me to
determine the mechanism for that right
now but there are discussions underway
right now looking at a whole spectrum
some in policing argue that people who
send mps abuse and death threats are
very different from the terrorists who
actually want to kill whatever the truth
politicians are clearly on the receiving
end of far more toxicity far more hate
than many people realize they don't
speak about it in public for fear of
making things worse and parliamentarians
do not agree on whether it can be
changed
this difficult debate will continue when
mps returned to westminster tomorrow the
uk's 45 territorial police forces are
now under pressure to reduce if not
eliminate the threat of further attacks
joe pike sky news